quand on parle de racisme anti blanc ça
me sens prometic alors ça veut pas dire
que les blancs ne sont pas exposées à
des discriminations à des injures
raciales
[Musique]
le racisme c'est une histoire une
histoire d'oppression qui a des
conséquences aujourd'hui être noir en
france ça veut dire être potentiellement
victimes de violences policières être
arabe aussi d'ailleurs être possiblement
agresser insulter etc
et c'est une expérience qui n'est pas
seulement une expérience individuelle
une expérience collective
une expérience qui peut aussi émané des
institutions c'est comme ça comme moi
quand on parle de racisme anti blanc
étant donné qu'il n'y a pas cette
histoire du racisme et qui n'a pas des
conséquences institutionnelles
ça me semble prometic alors ça veut pas
dire que les blancs ne sont pas exposées
à des discriminations à des injures
raciales et sage le déplore et je trouve
que c'est absolument inacceptable les
parler de racisme quand être blond en
france ça reste un avantage il vaut
mieux en france être blanc que arabe ou
que rome aucun dia tic parler de racisme
ça me semble déplacée c'est comme si on
parlait de sexisme anti homme parce que
quelques hommes seront battus quand on
est blanc en fait on ne vit pas avec
l'idée qu'on va expérimenter le racisme
dans sa vie alors qu'il n'y a pas une
seule personne non blanches qui a à un
moment de sa vie en france n'a pas été
renvoyé à sa couleur de peau de manière
négative et c'est ça la différence pour
moi ya pas dit il n'y a pas de théorie
en france qui ont mouillé rares chizé
sur le plan racial et qui ont dit les
blocs sont inférieurs ça ça n'existe pas
à ma connaissance
moi je ne connais pas de gens de
minorités qui revendique une supériorité
et qui ont pu établir des politiques
anti plat et c'est en ça que je trouve
qu'il ya une erreur quand on dit ça
c'est comme si j'avais l'impression
d'être victime des terreaux phobie parce
que je rentrais pas dans les bars gays
ou parce que des homosexuels de matthews
de la suite ma sexualité non la
sexualité que j'ai aujourd'hui à
dominante et c'est pas je peux pas dire
que je suis timide hétérophobie parce
que ça n'a aucun sens